Can you please discuss the value effectiveness of the foot detox?
So I think I touched on that a little bit. I think that can be beneficial. I told all of you
that personally, I don't do that at all anymore, but I was really sick. I did that a few times
at the office, but I don't, I just told somebody today that. I don't think I ever did it at home.
Do I, is it because I didn't think there's value in it? No. It's just that you have to weigh out
what you can do. You know, when I was doing, you know, my sauna, I was doing the PEMF. I was doing
the rife constantly. And plus I was working full time, you know, and you just had to weigh out.
Plus I had a life to live and I have a bunch of grandkids and kids and wife to tend to. And,
you know, you have to weigh what you can do. I didn't want treating my cancer to become a god in my life.
So you, I, some things had to go and, and doing the, I am pro wave. Sorry, true, right? But I didn't do it.
I, you know, but some of you think, oh, wow, I just find so much value. And then it really helps.
Well, then by all means, do that. So you just kind of, you got to weigh out what's going to be best for you.
If you haven't done it yet, I would do it and see how you like it. Some people love it. Just
absolutely love it. And, and continue to do it. So we have people on this call maybe that are,
that do it every single day because they think it just helps them so much. So